it's great to welcome to the program
Sean McFate who is senior fellow at the
Atlantic Council and also author most
recently of the new rules of war victory
in the age of durable disaster Sean it's
so great to have you back great to be
back with your day so we've been
following a lot of different
geopolitical and also sort of military
related stories we had what looked like
it was heading in the direction of a big
escalation with Iran that did not happen
we've been talking about the possible
different paths that the future of the
three big superpowers the US China and
Russia could could potentially take and
in that context talking about technology
militaries China's declining birthrate
and all of these different factors that
could play a role if you just word a big
picture for us the changes that we've
seen to the dynamics of the superpowers
over the last couple of years under
Donald Trump how what has changed I
guess is maybe where to start well the
first thing is that Donald Trump is
really doubling down on the defense
budget or the US military budget is
bigger than the next seven biggest
militaries in the world combined it's
sort of like the wrong Reagan buildup
and I think in some ways and there's a
shift away from terrorism to great power
competition like Russia and China Iran
and in some ways that's smart but what's
not smart is what we're investing in and
how we think we're gonna fight those
Wars if it becomes a war can you give
some examples of that in the sense that
I mean I think we we've talked about how
whenever there is a discussion of a
possible war now our minds probably
still go to the type of warfare of times
past and that's not realistically what
it would look like but what would it
look like what would the sort of battle
lines be so in the old rules of war the
way you won war is battlefield victory
take of Waterloo Gettysburg Stalingrad
Midway but what was the last time
battlefield victory sueda war in the
last 70 years no men - no times so
warfare
change we think in terms of conventional
war we think that the future war is good
like world war two with better
technology but in fact where work where
war is gone too is strategic deception
and what matters now is were speaking
epistemological so what matters now is
not like battlefield victory it matters
what people and populations think so
what does victory look like now well let
me ask you a question I mean like right
now we're we're engaged a cultural war
in the assets America right Fox vs. CNN
Democrats was Republican all those
things now we know that democracies are
messy and that's okay if we're having an
organic family dispute what's not okay
is if foreign powers are finding the
fissures in our society and Flajnik
fanning those flames deliberately and
that's indeed what's going on it's a
form of warfare it's and it's not
something that f-35 can fight is it so I
understand what you're saying I still
though so let me give you a counter
example and see where you think it fits
in in the discussion of a possible
escalation with Iran we saw some pretty
good pieces that said from a strategy
and tactics perspective Iran will be
very different than Iraq Iran's military
is much stronger than Iraq the land that
the sort of geographical realities of
Iran are very different than Iraq
mountainous and and very different those
seem like analyses more related to the
sort of traditional battlefield and they
seem relevant are they are they
partially relevant are they relevant in
a different way or is that not even a
reasonable analysis to be making it's
not a reasonable analysis at all really
I mean no I mean to invade Iran would be
like to invade China or to invade Moscow
you know both the Napoleon and the Nazis
learned not to invade Russia yeah just
because you have more troops and more
bullets does not mean you're going to
win wars so what's going on and I look
around what's going on in Iran right now
well we know we killed I mean we know
that Iran and Russia and the last ten
years have really
come to dominate Middle East politics we
kind of lost and Russia is filling the
void and so as Iran and the way they're
fighting is not like the iraq-iran war
of days of old they're using secret type
of weapons using Spetz
they were using a cut Special Forces
Hezbollah terrorists proxy groups
propaganda all these things and you know
what so does Russia they use Spetsnaz
they use mercenaries like the vogner
group they use a little green man these
fake proxy militias they use propaganda
and active measures that's how they took
the Crimea right and this is also how
Iran is taking the LaVon kind of taking
Syria and they're doing it not through
troops on the ground and tanks and
mountainous they're doing it through
deception and the reason is is that we
live in an Information Age where weapons
that give you plausible deniability like
terrorists and special forces of
propaganda weapons that give you
plausible deniability or more potent
than firepower we in the US are still
focusing on firepower but warfare has
completely changed Iran and Russia fight
this way we do not hmm so let's let's
keep talking about firepower a little
bit then nuclear weapons yeah a lot of
the conversation around Iran stemmed
from the 2015 Iran nuclear deal which as
far as we knew at the time that Donald
Trump decided to bail on it
Iran was abiding by of course since then
Iran has now said well if the US is out
we're not going to abide by it anymore
can you talk a little bit about in the
new sort of framework of what war would
look like what role do nuclear weapons
have because often the conversation is
merely about if the u.s. gets to have
them who are we to say Iran doesn't the
legitimacy of the UN Security Council
that's often the conversation I got a
call or a couple of weeks ago who said
you know David what's not being
discussed is it's possible that Iran
getting nuclear weapons could be a
moderating influence in the sense that
sometimes once countries have nuclear
weapons they see themselves as part of a
sort of different tier or a chillon and
it
actually toned down radical rhetoric
what what do you think about that where
do you come down on the role of nuclear
weapons in new warfare it's a great
question
first of all the jcpoa jcpoa is on
hospice care it's done and we also know
that Russia is working behind the scenes
the UN to let the arms embargo on Iran
expire so that come October we can see
you know Iran and Russia really doubling
down on conventional weapons terms of
nuclear weapons WMD it's probably
inevitable that we that Iran at some
point will get a nuclear weapon we can
bomb Natanz with a nuclear will take a
nuclear weapon maybe a JDAM to hit it
that will slow it down we can also try
to assassinate their scientists as
Israel is done that can slow it down but
I think we have to be prepared to live
in a world that may have a nuclear Iran
and if they do we have to ask ourselves
are they really going to deploy it I
mean everybody assumes they're going to
deploy it and I don't know if that's
true people send us about North Korea
before North Korea became nuclear and in
fact once Iran is a nuclear power we
still have levers of power levers of
diplomacy we can pull on them it's not
Armageddon despite their fierce rhetoric
I'm not being an apologist for Iran but
there are people who treat it like ass
the moment they get a nuclear weapon is
a moment you know you know Tel Aviv and
New York City go up in a mushroom cloud
and I think some of that is just
fear-mongering well there's no question
that the use of a nuclear weapon would
be would be self-destructive there's no
question about that but I guess the
broader question is when it comes to
policy would the presence of or the more
serious potential to have a nuclear
weapon make that country perceived as
more important to negotiate with I mean
there are examples from history we can
look at Iran we can look at you know
within within the Soviet Union instances
where there has been disarming where
there have been agreements to disarm
that the future has not gone
particularly well for some of those
countries so if you look at history it's
understandable why countries would see
nuclear weapons or at least the serious
potential of them as a good negotiating
tool or something that's good to have
that's right I mean look at North Korea
they were they were treated as a b-list
player at best before they got nuclear
weapons now people pay attention to them
when they may they speak and they're not
gonna give up a nuclear weapon despite
whatever the Trump administration
promises look at Ukraine they gave up
their nuclear weapons after the Serbian
collapsed the United States promised
them oh we'll protect you of Russia ever
gets aggressive and then when Russia got
aggressive in 2014 the u.s. broke its
promise so I think the entire world
knows that's better to have nuclear
weapons than not it shouldn't just go to
the victors of you know world war two I
think the danger is a nuclear world war
one Syria of a moment if Iran ever gets
a nuclear weapon we know Israel has
nuclear weapons and many believe that
Saudi Arabia has a secret deal with
Pakistan Saudi Arabia used to have a
nuclear program 70s 80s and the u.s.
they you know talk them out of it but
some believe that they that Saudi is
made a secret do a Pakistan giving them
all the research and all their money and
said you develop nuclear weapons and if
we ever need one we'll just secretly buy
a dozen from you and so very quickly we
could have a nuclear Iran you know Saudi
Arabia Israel and there's a threat of
accidental war like in 1914 Syria of a
moment but it doesn't last for four
years at last you know 30 minutes and
that would be tragic what do you see is
the role of organizations like the
United Nations we've talked about NATO a
lot since Donald Trump has been
president and shared defense treaties
there's this streak of both I mean it
starts with nationalism but it often
leads to a sort of isolationism in some
cases what what do you see is the role
of multinational organizations joint
defense treaties etc in the next 10
fifteen years it's a great question I
mean first of all the question of NATO
is long overdue and Donald Trump's not
the first person asked what's their
mission right that's that's hardly new I
do you think that international
organizations United Nations have passed
their expiration date they have failed
to evolve with the world right now we're
in a world where you know it's not the
world that we imagine the world
diplomats imagined is state centric you
know states are everything and
everything that's not state is called
sub state politics but we live in a
world with a fortune 500 are more
powerful than most states where the
SuperDuper rich the 0.1% globally are
more powerful than than the most states
and we're mercenaries are back so
anybody who's rich enough can can go to
war for any reason they want that means
anybody can swipe a paycheck to become a
superpower eventually Exxon Mobil gets
its own army Bill Gates gets his own
army megachurches
oligarchs they all get their own
militaries so the UN is still stuck in
the state centric worldview and they're
not though they're not likely to leave
that and so is international law which
is why they become less and less
relevant from mitigating and managing
conflicts around the world whether
that's Rwanda or the Congo or Iraq or
Afghanistan at most or just a rubber
stamp they're just they're stationed
area and most and I think they either
have a you don't have to evolve or
they're just going to become lip service
what would what would the evolution of
an organization like NATO look like of
NATO I think that NATO is I think NATO's
past is expiration date because after
after the Cold War it stopped becoming a
military alliance became a pro-democracy
alliance and now it's it's kind of run
half by diplomat diplomatic think and
half by military I think if there's
going to be a real alliance of
collective security lives look at what
Poland is doing on the east so Eastern
Europe they take Russians threaten very
seriously and they're kind of forming a
an informal security cooperation pact
and I think something like that might be
more of a model but it needs to be Nia
would have to be once and again seized
with defense as its primary mission and
not being used as a tool for you know
human rights and democracy as important
as those things are that's not the
original nature of a defense Alliance
we've been speaking with Sean McFate who
is a senior fellow at the Atlantic
Council also author most recently of the
book the new rules of war victory in the
age of durable disaster Sean so great
having you on today
thank you David's great to be back in
your shell